es ist kaum möglich sich auf Facebook
Instagram und tiktok und anderen nicht
mit anderen Menschen zu vergleichen dein
eigenes Leben kommt dir Scheiße vor
warum räumst du eigentlich gerade die
Spülmaschine aus wenn du auch in Slomo
aus dem Helikopter springen kannst und
dann riesigen Berg runter Snowboard ist
während sich hinter den Lawine löst was
los mit dir du opfer da kannst du dir
zehnmal sagen dass es nicht die Realität
ist im Schnitt sind Jugendliche von 12
bis 19 Jahren in Deutschland jeden Tag
und dreieinhalb Stunden online wenn du
dreieinhalb Stunden am Tag online bist
und gefilterte Menschen die es ist das
dann eben deine Realität Jugendliche
sehen im Schnitt 5000 Bilder die Woche
so oft kannst du gar nicht in die Sauna
oder ins Freibad gehen um zu merken ah
ja so sehen Menschen realistisch aus